j'avais hâte de parler au docteur
caroline courage depuis ce matin bonsoir
docteur couach
gdg des questions vraiment très simple
pour vous on va revenir un peu aux
points fondamentaux concernant la
vaccination parce que là on a entend
parfois quelque chose et son contraire
les doubles vacciner docteur couach dans
quelle mesure sont ils protégés devant
le micro que nous dit la science la
science nous dit que quand l'écran ils
sont plus protégés surtout quand on
rendu à peu près six mois post deuxième
dose donc il ya une protection d'à peu
près 30 à 40% contre les infections qui
augmente à autour de 75 % la dose de
rappel on est loin du 93 % qui était la
protection entre la dose de rappel pour
le variant des ltte
mais quand même mieux que ceux qui
restent après deux doses non 3e 12 parce
que là on insiste partout sur cette
troisième donges le plus vite possible
est-elle efficace protège-t-elle le cepd
en compte le micro mais c'est donc la
troisième dose protège autour de 75%
contre le look rose que je vous disais
que cette troisième dose de protéger à
93% contre mariant des ltte contre les
hospitalisations s'assemblent la
protection de deux doses semblent à peu
près maintenu autour de 70% alors qu'on
était à 95% contre les variantes des
ltte maintenant on a encore très très
peu de données le canton de protection
de cette troisième dose de comté
hospitalisation mais on s'attend à ce
que ça soit meilleur que contre les
infections donc au-delà de 75%
probablement plutôt autour de 85 90 on
nous disait au québec notamment que la
deuxième dose allaient être bonnes pour
une durée moins six mois et que bon là
on dit bon ben on va on recommande après
cinq mois et il ya des endroits que
c'est encore moins de cinq mois qu'en
est il à quel moment la troisième dose
devient idéal
en fait avec le micro on a l'impression
que c'est une relative on était de la
donner le plus rapidement possible
maintenant il faut réussir à prioriser
les gens qui m'envient va avoir droit à
cette dose dans premier habituellement
ce qu'on appelle faire jeter toujours de
prioriser les plus vulnérables et c'est
pour ça que les plus âgés sont passés
d'abord les travailleurs basson et les
gens avec malades chroniques et ensuite
on continuera à déployer jusqu'à l'hiver
le bol mais êtes vous êtes d'accord avec
l'insistance qu'on entend partout bon au
québec on dit on peut pas aller plus
vite parce qu'ils manquent de d'employés
mais vous êtes d'accord avec donc cette
affirmation que la troisième dodge va
vraiment nous protéger davantage contre
le micro la troisième dose va nous
protéger davantage
je pense qu'il faut pas se mettre la
tête dans le sable est on est on ne peut
pas on ne peut pas ne pas penser aux
mesures non pharmacologiques donc de
deux distances physiques qu'on l'avait
mis en place au départ la
transmissibilité de ce virus là est
tellement grande que on n'arrivera
jamais à laxmi suffisamment bien pour
faire un mur ça ce virus-là donc eu
l'idée c'est vraiment de limiter le plus
possible le nombre de contacts à
l'intérieur sont minces pour ralentir la
transmission parce que il semble ce
virus sur le produira une équipe
extraordinaire dans les dix ans et donc
devient excessivement comptage est bon
ben vous m'amenez ma dernière question
je vous la posez tout de suite je
reviendrai au voyage après donc noël
rassemblement est ce que vous croyez
qu'on doit être encore plus claire au
québec notamment et de dire ce n'est pas
une bonne idée de se rassembler plus que
5 10 15
où vous en êtes dans votre réflexion
face à noël
honnêtement c'est de dire 5 2 ce week
end là n'est pas la question si on fait
cinq personnes x 6 sur trois jours
c'était pas mieux que de faire 30 d'un
coup le encore une fois l'idée c'est
vraiment de limiter le plus possible les
contacts puis à la limite si on lit les
mêmes vins pendant deux semaines dans un
chalet pour moi une fois qu'on sait
qu'on n'est plus à risque le
multi gilles donc cette espèce
d'obsession comme il dit tout à l'heure
la savoir on peut avoir exactement comme
une personne dans la maison un moment
donné c'est un peu sa perte ici est
qu'on veut c'est
possible le nombre de personnes qu'on
rencontre essayer de limiter nos
contacts avec d'autres avant d'arriver à
ces rassemblements chaque douleur et
ypres et maïali avec la maison la plus
grande pour qu'on ait le plus d'espacé
possible entre les gens pour avec un
potentiel de 10 sion tient une
ventilation d'aération la meilleure
possible mais ce qu'on veut c'est être
le moins possible à risques est arrivé à
notre party de noël avec un ami combat
c'est de la musique à mes oreilles ce
que vous dit que l'auteur quoi je vous
dis soirée était l'obsession puis
vraiment je le dis je me suis permis de
le dire tout à l'heure avec sébastien
l'obsession de 10 12 15 l'idée comme
vous avez bien expliquer ces les
nouveaux contacts limités c'est comme
les boules de bien sûr un sur une table
de bien si on reste le même groupe tout
est bon mais il ya moins de contacts
nouveau mais si on se promène avec plein
de sous groupes c'est là le problème
directement bon voyage vous avez entendu
à ottawa aujourd'hui on nous dit c'est
pas une bonne idée jal est pris d'abord
prêté pour venir parce que si vous êtes
si vous attrapez la coved jeu pour
mexique peu importe où
vous pourrez pas avec un test positif
reprendre l'avion pour revenir au canada
qu'est ce que j'en pense et les voyages
c'est vraiment je pense que ce qui est
compliqué c'est de savoir une fois
vendues à l'étranger ce qui va arriver
est ce qu'on va pouvoir revenir
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont demander comme
comme la mesure pour reprendre l'avion
encore une fois si le mitron est partout
au canada de limiter l'arrivée de
nouveaux cadeaux mitron c'est une mesure
qui ne qui n'est pas la cuisse efficace
mais je pense que c'est vraiment pour 2
0 au canadien que si jamais il participe
à tulle que ça change vraiment pire je
n'y vois la docteure couach très clair
merci beaucoup nous avons parlé ce soit
merci bonne soirée au revoir